cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com Russell Brand cancels comedy
dates after sexual assault allegations
the comedian was scheduled to perform
three dates in Britain this month now
they've been postponed he's also been
dropped from his talent agency shows on
Channel 4 have been pulled there's
pressure on the BBC and Netflix to pull
his shows yo they are coming after
Russell Brand with Force I have not seen
uh in a long time I mean look they come
after him and apparently there is a
criminal investigation underway as well
but I hear people talking about on
Twitter and Andrew Tate says Matrix
attack that's what he calls it some
people are comparing this to uh what
they did to Andrew Tate but I think what
they did to Andrew take what they're
doing to him is a bit more extreme
they're accusing me of like outright
trafficking and stuff like this but I do
find it very interesting that uh Russell
Brand is being so heavily targeted for
one simple reason
Epstein has been accused of doing uh so
much more and for such a long period of
time to the point where he was actually
criminally prosecuted where you actually
had ABC News Amy rohrback saying we got
him we got this story and then dropping
it
when you have someone as devious and
malicious evil as Epstein and they do
nothing and then you have Russell Brand
and they're like did you know that 10
years ago 15 years ago in one instance
they're saying it was 17 years ago it's
like two decade old allegations and
apparently I don't even know if these
allegations some of them are not even
criminal they're like he was abusive
emotionally like this is all part of the
story you know they're destroying
they're trying to destroy this guy's
career and pull him off out of the face
of the of the of of of mainstream
conversations and and commentary
for decades-old allegations I just I
gotta say right off the bat it seems
kind of strange so I do want to play for
you this clip here because this is
sparking conspiracy number one
Simon atiba Says many are now saying
this clip this video clip might be why
Russell Brand is being attacked watch
let's play this clip from Real Time with
Bill Maher this thing's probably got I
don't know 50 million views because it's
being reposted everywhere but here you
go
actually you guess we just get the
out of here
he said he's gonna give him facts
I wouldn't have mentioned it I'm English
and you know that politeness is our
fundamental religion
but they do pertain to this issue so may
I say something please say inconvenience
you I'll stop saying them the pandemic
created at least 40 new far big Pharma
billionaires pharmaceutical corporations
like moderna and Pfizer made a thousand
dollars of profit every second from the
covid-19 vaccine more than two-thirds of
Congress received campaign funding from
pharmaceutical companies in the 2020
election Pfizer chairman Albert baller
told Time magazine in July 2020 that his
company was developing a covered vaccine
for the good of humanity not for money
and of course Pfizer made a hundred
billion dollars in profit in 2022. and
may I just mentioned that finally and
these are this is also a fact that you
the American public funded the
development of that the German Republic
funded the bio and Tech vaccine when it
came to of the prophets they took the
profits when it came to the funding you
paid for the funding all I'm querying is
this yes is if you have an economic
system in which pharmaceutical companies
benefit hugely from medical emergencies
where a military industrial complex
benefits from war where an energy
companies benefit from energy crisis you
are going to generate states of
Perpetual crisis where the interests of
Ordinary People well yes and separate
from the interests of the elite and he
hit the nail on there with the Hamilton
people are saying like that's it right
there I'm not gonna go I don't I think
it's silly to say this one clip did it
because I think I don't know once this
clip from do we even know when the show
was I'm pretty sure it was from a while
ago but I will say it's that kind of
sentiment that's going to make you a lot
of enemies I'm still waiting for my
Pfizer check that's for sure but are you
guys sponsored I know all these media
companies are you know sponsored by
Pfizer all these news outlets I'll tell
you this could be first of all you know
innocent or proven guilty how many times
have you seen allegations go against an
athletes someone who
seems to be not part of the whole Matrix
they call right someone that's not in in
bed with the elites how many times have
you seen the allegations come the name
drug through the mud for two a year or
two all the all to find out in the end
that there's no charges nothing ever
happens but then what happens is you you
get uh associated with being a rapist
you get if say say Russell Brand say
that that this goes on for some time
everything you know nothing happens
right oh innocent nothing really that we
see that's gonna get him jail time
people are still gonna say oh didn't he
rape women yeah anytime his name comes
in an article
Russell Brand who was accused of this
whether or not anything's actually
proven right they'll put the commas
Russell Brand comma who is accused of
multiple rapes comma right and it taints
your legacy and and I think he he says a
whole lot more than than this this is
big he's he's you know obviously saying
information people may not know that
that's good to know and and I think uh
they're going after him because they're
trying to set the tone that if you
revolt if you're going against anything
that we're displeased with right now in
time this could be you you could be the
one next that that's getting this you
know injust system I think that the
justice system is becoming
um you know completely favorable to the
elites who can kind of do whatever they
want I think it's always been kind of
like it's getting worse though they're
doing it in front of our faces now now
it's just like you know with jaywalking
we don't like this guy look at oh who'd
he vote for look at them yeah give them
two years in prison and then someone
over here does the worst thing you could
possibly do and and it's just somehow
they program all of our minds to not
care that they kill all these people or
do I think this could simply be if you
are outside the establishment and
mainstream narrative you are not allowed
to be in the establishment and the
mainstream so this could be for a lot of
reasons one uh super teachers popped in
the OMG Puppies made a good point saying
that he's anti-war he's anti-ukraine war
and for the UK I mean they're they're
more serious they're starting to
depleted uh depleted uranium tank
Busters I think they're called these and
and Putin said that these are basically
nuclear weapons so you've got someone in
the UK doing that they excise him from
everything this is their way to reduce
his influence I don't think they care
about the aftermath they're basically
saying he should not be on mainstream
television he should not be on Netflix
BBC Channel 4 he should be in the in the
gutters of society along with Alex Jones
and you name it they should not be
platformed as it were how do you get
someone off of a network if Russell
Brand is featured in these TV shows they
generate attention for him and that
brings people to his podcast where he
outright says we should not be funding
War we should not be funding big
pharmaceutical companies okay you got a
problem well you can't just sever the
contracts you have with them unless you
have a morality violation now you have
your morality Clause violation against
Russell Brand impropriety and it's like
why would his talent agency drop him
overnight it's like come on there's not
a conviction it doesn't matter this is
their way of saying we are removing him
from polite Society because we don't
like the things he has to say and it's
funny because they they none of this
came out when he's playing the role of a
guy that all he does is drink through
drugs and have sex right that we want to
represent this guy he's the perfect guy
or the years that he spent talking about
his sex addiction in his stand-up comedy
right like right he was open about the
fact that he lived essentially a
degenerate lifestyle I mean it was
fueled by addiction it's complicated I
get that but no one thought ah yes while
his uh initial star was Rising I should
come forward with these allegations
right he has been a popular name for a
long time why now well when the casting
comes in and and the casting says
looking for sex addicted rock star you
know literally his agent's like that's
my guy you know I have the perfect guy
and then he you find out now they're
trying to say he does these things in
real life and you're like I kind of
figured that was the case anyway but
they're just trying to put a Bad spin on
what I think
um I want to see it I want to see the
other well I mean accusing the dude of
rape I think is is completely over the
top right right you might look at him
and be like 10 years later yeah but like
to to assume that he has these behaviors
because of his character and his Persona
and stuff it's like well no I might I
might assume that he's at like crazy
clubs and parties and doing nasty stuff
but not abusing people I mean that's
like accusing him of like I wouldn't
assume Russell Brands committing crimes
against people you know what I mean you
know it's crazy that two people can get
drunk black out drunk have sex for not
even know they did it because they're
blacked out then the next morning the
woman can say I didn't I didn't agree to
that I wasn't cognitively but a man
can't if if I if that happened to a
woman and they're both blackout drunk
the woman can say I was raped but the
man can't say I was raped which is
terrible right like I thought we I
thought we're the feminists I thought we
were all gender equal why can't men well
did it too but the fault is always on
the mat no but didn't someone do this
there was a guy who came out and said
that he was raped by some woman like
abruptly yeah this happened once and
everyone I can't remember who this was
everybody was like uh oh you see the
game he's playing he's gonna be the
first one to make the accusation so that
he can't be accused because he's he's
the one making the accusation I can't
remember there's a story maybe people in
the chat won't remember I mean similar
stuff comes up when you get you know
high school students who sleep with
their teacher and everyone's like wow
great job but if it's a girl they're
like that man was out of control which
of course in both scenarios the adult is
in the wrong there here's something
funny too people need to watch out
before I mention this on my morning show
they say that Russell Brand one of the
accusers was 16 at the time and you're
like whoa that's that's crazy but you
got to ask yourself first how old was
Russell Brand because imagine you know
if someone came out was like Ian
Crossland dated a 16 year old when he
was 16. that's actually true right so
it's like the saying Ian Ian Crossland
dated a 16 year old people were like
whoa that's crazy
this is a fact and we need to see if
this is actually you could just say see
we're hearing hearsay right now I want
to see the facts I want to see the case
I'm not just gonna call him rapist and
then two years later like he actually
never did it and then right he's still
this rape but I I don't want to say one
more thing too uh Russell Brown's 31 at
the time of the allegations of the 16
year old and so it's it's like I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna give the guy a free
pass either agree there's accusations
innocent until proven guilty I don't
think he should lose his job at all just
because his claims are coming out and
they're not even I I think these claims
for the most part are not even claims
claims of criminality I think there may
be a couple but in the instance of a 16
year old I think that the age of consent
as all the news reports are saying it
was legal doesn't mean good like 31 year
old hitting up a 16 year old kind of
weird not assuming it's true but
criminal and then it's a question of I
mean are we gonna look dude is this 20
years ago if the dude committed a crime
or whatever we hold them accountable I
just think
when you have Epstein and they don't
care at all and weirdly none of his
victims seem to be allowed to come
forward at all ever a couple of them do
and then we suddenly they get where's
that Client List yeah Maria farmer she's
got a I'm just the one listen to her
it's just amazing what were you saying
Ian I don't I don't I don't know I
didn't read this part of the story you
mentioned that like a journalist reached
out to these women I was people were
saying that he's being targeted I'm like
well let's look into it and then I
looked into it and apparently a
journalist took it upon herself to
contact these women and be like do you
want to be in a story about Russell do
you want to accuse Russell Brand do you
want to and like ask these people to
come out and I don't know if this is 100
I haven't like been able to confirm or
deny because I don't know the behind the
scenes workings but it sounds like it
was a reporter that kind of put all this
together I just wanna I wanna I wanna
say uh I'll say two quick things because
we we got some great messages in the
chat uh this is uh I'm true said that he
said you said it Tim they're going to go
after lawyers for doing nothing next to
be media personalities yeah I didn't
think this would be like in relation to
j6 right I didn't mean like someone like
Russell Brand I meant people who are
actively promoting j6 but I do want to
say
this is modern assassination
the way they the way they target people
uh uh powerful Elites corrupt
individuals mafias whatever back in the
day was assassination
they that that's reserved now for
extreme circumstances related to
International conflict War what they do
now you can observe with Julian Assange
falsely accused of rape to tame to the
media you then got all of these Intel
asset media agencies prominent major
media they kept saying Julian Assange
raped a woman he was accused of rape
none of it was true he was never accused
of rape that never happened right then
they then they lock him up for it and he
knows the charges are bunk and so then
he goes to the Ecuadorian Embassy and
then the media runs the attack again and
again and again Julian Assange flees
rape charges rape charges there was
never a rape charge he was never accused
of raping anybody the media just kept
lying about it because character
assassination is how you do it if you
assassinate someone let's say and and
look I love this the you know the media
is going to be like conspiracy theories
dude come on assassinations get to get
busted all the time we know what happens
the dark web has these things if you're
if they are trying to take out someone
who's politically powerful or
influential and that person dies they
become a martyr people paint pictures of
their face on a wall so the modern
technique is destroy the image of the
person first and then make make it
unacceptable or Unthinkable to say their
name or cite them yeah I would call This
Modern banishment where you used to
actually throw them out of the country
now you debank them and make their make
them Asian drop them and stuff it
doesn't matter where they live they're
just not welcome to be part of the
society and you're getting banished for
what for for trying to start uh uh or
try to inform the civilian Millions
trying to start a revolution of some
sorts for us because we know at this
point that we're fed up right all of us
uh there's a lot to be fed up about and
it it brings fear for for communities it
brings fear for leaders to step out and
say we're not going to take any more of
this we're standing up to this and it's
going to make less people want to want
to you know kind of put their put their
foot down and and revolt against
the abuse of power that's been happening
uh extremely the past few years I mean
it's been happening our whole life our
whole lifetime but it's really really
getting done in front of our face more
recently and I've got little kids to
raise so I I want them to to grow up in
a good civilization right so they can
just do this to you they can just you
know 30 years for January 6th which was
obviously
planned and and kind of scripted out to
happen that way and then and then look
what they do they they're setting an
example for anybody that wants to be a
part of any form of Revolution that's a
problem because we may need a revolution
at some point during our lifetime thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time